which is how I don't you guys so we just
like gave you some truth that I feel
like that you want a job right vaca give
me quick girl okay time for the house
lady change it I'm gonna do this never
play Jenga
no cheating we're cheating yeah we're
gonna wait cheating right yeah okay wait
cut you oh good I got it
dare oh no tell us the last celebrity
who texted you probably you guys I know
ed over but you are doing it's so funny
so looking on leaning on she's dead I'm
sure yeah brooches she said you're in
ketchup [ __ ] yeah
put it up chopped oh oh all right she
doesn't sister who can we bad at this
all right let me see here nice oh oh
yeah there's a lot of genka just yep
like crazy like oh you've been in it is
gonna do this bro playing stand back
okay
who would you trust to help you take
care of a dead body
oh man um I know I don't know I guess I
don't jump I used to have this is a
contractor and I think he may have
offered that to me there we go now yeah
yeah I know we have a member that goes
oh I'm not good at this oh it's not even
listening to me good
it's big thank you dare do a handstand
Oh
hey everybody do a headstand you could
what he'll back out outfit no no drink
all honey
okay Podesta now I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try to oh my goodness oh oh did you want
cool oh my god it was loud that was
incredible incredible isn't it crazy
that we can all do this oh god the
suspense
what would be your ideal bachelorette
party okay um not gendering it letting
my husband do their to just smoking and
drinking and doing jobs and no
activities and just like a house on a
beach with like a bunch of friends and
like cooking
that sounds very yeah I don't even need
a bachelor buddy I could just deal with
the [ __ ] way to do that I would love
that yeah just a little vacay I might
after we're done with this string up
yeah you know I would hope I would try
to poke them through this one not it's
really easy there you go vagina the
heart competition no I have just written
but haha it's legit 11:45 or something
Jenga whoa good job oh my god you're so
[ __ ] projet I'm a nobody of the buzz
in BuzzFeed confess something you've
done that people would be shocked to
know do not order from Haynes online
that's all I'm saying
the bad customer service and I've been
arguing with what I think may be
something that's like an automated kind
of yeah arguing with a computer not just
for fun the fact that you're taking the
time is surprising I like it
that's a shot hit in general okay there
you go
hold your nose and Hum the national
anthem
[Music]
[Music]
keychain that was a key to everyone here
that's huge turn up
oh yeah little ornamentation
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you're really good dearest oh thank you
oh my god I am such I am such a loose
grip what if I'm at some of the toniest
moments I'm such oh my question family
performing so hardcore
and um okay one of the funny moment on
set was that this [ __ ] dude who is so
angry that we were shooting we're
shooting in a house he was like yelling
stuff and you could like telly was races
feeling at the crew and it was like you
knew dude you knew that we were really
coming down and I think the production
like maybe to you like what are you
yelling at us for and also like the
lighting guy doesn't give a [ __ ] if you
if you are you can't sleep I think he
asked I wonder if they wanted to meet
God yeah yeah like he was gonna give
them are you gonna meet you in a meet go
from Gaza and that's hilarious
Oh get away my feelings are as yours
like wow did anyone witness that scarlet
just straight up stole mature I'm sorry
I was easy mom who would you trust to
help you take care of it
oh my goodness honestly I need oh yes
good for you know a person is like it's
fine let's do it okay yeah no you don't
go I would also be the coolest cuz how
they get caught you oh yeah that sucks
don't know what you got this guy we have
at our quarry which are hard yeah do you
want to go for me no way they'll be oh
it looks pupae tweet is this one you can
always yeah oh yeah do it it's good
Stahl's yeah here catch one she did mine
oh we're all eating anyway wave your
phone to the person next to you and let
them FaceTime the most famous person in
your phone yeah I mean I thank you give
me no I can't
hi kids God Risa vodka there's no way I
can't you guys
Julia mother eyes I have a weight
resistance closetful oh my god I've got
a world to save people kill it is just
[Music]
feel free PS create fellas
mm-hmm all right where are we going
honestly don't know laughs I did a shot
of vodka
you
Oh